Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've
learned a whole bunch
of different
integration techniques.
So I have here a
couple of problems
that will give
you an opportunity
to apply those techniques, and
figure out which ones to apply.
So in particular I have
one definite integral,
the integral 0 to 2 of
the quantity x times e
to the 1 minus x squared
with respect to x.
And the second one is
an indefinite integral
of 2 arctan x divided by x
squared with respect to x.
So why don't you pause
the video, take some time
to work these out, come back,
and we can work them out
together.
Welcome back.
Hopefully you had some luck
working on these integrals.
Let's get started.
We can do the first one
first, and then we'll
go on to the second one.
So here we want to compute the
integral from 0 to 2 of x e
to the 1 minus x squared dx.
So in order to do this, we
have to, you know-- well,
we could look at it and say, do
I know the answer immediately,
off the top of my head?
And this is not one
of the, you know,
ones that we have
immediately already memorized
a formula for.
So then you say, OK.
So now I need to do something
in order to try to integrate it.
And so, you know, you have
a whole bunch of techniques.
And for this one,
when you look at it,
the technique that is
going to work for you
is just the simplest
technique that you have,
which is just a
straightforward substitution.
And one way to figure that out,
is that you can look at this
and you can see
that here we have
a composition of functions,
this e to the 1 minus x
squared, and so
whenever you have
a composition of
functions, there's
the opportunity for there
to have been a chain
rule somewhere.
And in this case, we see that
this composition of functions
is multiplied by x, and
x is very closely related
to the derivative of
1 minus x squared.
So that's what's suggesting
for us a nice substitution.
And so the substitution
we're going to try, then,
is that we're going to
put this inside function,
this 1 minus x squared, we're
going to set u equal to that.
So, all right.
So this is equal to--
so I'm going to say,
u equal 1 minus x squared.
So now if I take a differential,
if u equals 1 minus x squared,
that means that
du is minus 2x dx.
And since this is a
definite integral,
I also need to change the
bounds of integration.
So when x is equal to 0, that
means that u is equal to,
well, 1 minus 0 squared is
1, so that's the lower bound.
And when x is equal
to 2, that means
that u is equal to 1 minus 2
squared, which is negative 3.
So we make these substitutions.
OK.
So what does our
integral become?
So this becomes the integral--
so now the lower bound
becomes u equals 1,
and the upper bound
is u equals negative 3.
OK.
So now e to the 1
minus x squared,
that's just e to the u.
And x dx-- well,
that's almost du.
It's du divided by negative 2.
So du divided by negative 2.
So we make the substitution.
We transform our
integral to this form.
Now, this is a very nice,
simple integral, right?
This is just the integral of
e to the u with a, you know,
a constant multiple.
So, OK.
So we can do this right away.
So this is-- I'll pull the
minus 1/2 out in front.
And now fundamental
theorem of calculus.
Antiderivative of the e to
the u is just e to the u.
And I have to take
that between my bounds.
So between u equals 1
and u equals minus 3.
So notice that because
we changed bounds,
we don't have to go back and
convert everything back to x.
We can just plug in directly.
So OK.
So we plug in directly.
What do I get?
So first I get minus
1/2 times-- all right,
so I'll just pull the
constant out in front.
So the first term is e to the
minus third minus e to the 1.
OK.
And if I wanted to, I could
rewrite this as e minus e
to the minus 3 over 2, or
in a variety of other ways.
All right.
So this one was a pretty
straightforward integration
by substitution.
Definite integral, change
bounds, and at the end
you get this answer.
So let's take a look
at the second one.
So the second one is a
bit trickier, I think,
and it requires a bit more work.
So here it is.
Let me rewrite it.
So it's the antiderivative of
2 arctan x over x squared dx.
So we have here
an antiderivative
that we have to compute.
And this is a kind of
messy-looking expression
that we're working with.
All right?
So this is not very pleasant.
So there are a couple
of different things
we could think to do.
So one thing that you could
think to do is you could say,
I really don't like arctan.
I'm going to try and
get rid of arctan.
And the way I'm going
to get rid of arctan
is by doing a substitution,
u equals arctan x,
or x equals tan u.
So if you do that,
that'll get rid
of your inverse trigonometric
function, but it'll introduce,
in the bottom, you
have this x squared,
so that'll introduce
like a tan u squared,
and dx will give you
some more trig functions.
So what you'll be
left with, then-- so
this will be u on top.
So you'll have u times a
product of trig functions.
So I guess it's up
to you whether you
think that a polynomial,
or a power of u
times a bunch of trig functions,
is simpler than an inverse trig
function times a power.
It's not clear to me that it's
actually that much simpler.
And in any case,
we wouldn't sort of
be finished at that stage.
There would still be a fair
amount more work to do.
So we can think about, what
other things could we do?
That's kind of the only
obvious substitution here.
But another thing
that suggests itself,
is that we could try an
integration by parts.
And one reason is, this
is a product of things.
You know, here it's arctan
x times 1 over x squared.
And arctan x is something that
works nicely with integration
by parts if you can
differentiate it.
Right?
So inverse
trigonometric functions
behave like logarithms
with respect
to integration by parts.
By which I mean, they really
like to be differentiated.
Because when you
differentiate an arctan,
you get something much simpler.
Well, simpler, anyhow.
Maybe not much simpler.
You get 1 over 1 plus x squared.
So if you can apply
integration by parts
and differentiate the arctan,
that makes your life nice.
And so, then, in order
for that to work,
you need for everything
else to be something
you can antidifferentiate, and
here everything else is just 2
over x squared, and
so that's something
that we know how to integrate.
It's easy to do.
So, OK.
So let's give that a try, then.
So we're going to do integration
by parts, so I'm going
to set u equal to arctan x.
So that means u prime is equal
to 1 over 1 plus x squared.
And I'm going to
let v prime equal,
well, I guess I have to
pick up the 2 somewhere,
so I might as well
pick it up here.
2 over x squared.
And so then v, so I
integrate 2 over x squared,
so that gives me x to the
minus 1, with a minus sign.
So it's minus 2 over x.
So these are u, u
prime, v and v prime.
So now OK, so now I apply
integration by parts,
and that tells me this is
equal to-- well, let's see.
So it's u*v, which is
minus 2 arctan x over x.
That's u*v. Minus the integral
of, now it's the second part,
it's v u prime dx.
So here v u prime is-- well, OK.
So they're minus 2.
I'm going to pull
that out front.
So it's plus 2-- all right.
And then the rest of
it is 1 over x times 1
plus x squared dx.
So if you apply
integration by parts,
you have the u*v stuff that
gets kicked out out front,
and then what you're left
with is this second integral.
Now this is, to me this is
simpler-looking than what
we started with.
It's still not simple,
but it's simpler.
So it seems to me that,
you know, having reached
this stage, we can say, OK.
We've made some progress, and
now we have to keep going.
Right?
So it's not obvious to me
what the antiderivative
of this expression should be.
So how can I figure that out?
Well, there are a couple
of different options here.
One thing you might
look at this and see,
is you might see--
again, I have a 1
plus x squared in
the denominator,
and so that might
make you tempted to do
a trig substitution again.
And in fact, you could do
a trig substitution here.
You could put x equal
tan theta, and you
would be able to solve
the question like this.
But I don't think it's
the simplest way to go.
Because in addition--
well, on the one hand,
this has this 1 plus x
squared in the denominator,
but on the other hand, this
is just a rational function.
Yeah?
It's a ratio of two polynomials.
The polynomial on top is
just 1, and the polynomial
on the bottom is this product,
x times 1 plus x squared.
And so whenever you have a
rational function that you're
trying to integrate,
you can also
always use-- what's it called--
partial fraction decomposition.
So we can try to use
partial fractions
on the second expression.
And so I think I'd
like to do it that way.
So let's do that.
Let's do it down here.
So partial fractions
on the quantity 1
over x times 1 plus x squared.
So if you remember your
partial fractions here,
this is completely factored.
This quadratic doesn't factor.
It doesn't have any real
roots, doesn't factor.
So OK, so we have a
single linear term,
and a single non-factorable
quadratic term.
So partial fractions tells
us that we can write this
in the form A over x plus-- and
now because the second term is
quadratic, it needs to be B*x
plus C over 1 plus x squared.
Right?
So when you have a
quadratic in the bottom,
you get two constants up at
the top, a linear polynomial.
And then you can always check.
You have three constants
here, and the degree
of the denominator
is 3, so that's
one way of checking that
you're not completely off base,
that the degree down
here should always
agree with the
number of constants
that you're solving for.
OK.
Good.
So now we need to solve
this for A, B, and C.
And so OK, because we have
this nice single linear factor,
we can do the cover
up method there.
So we cover up x, and
we cover up over x,
and we cover up everything else.
So on the right-hand
side, we just
end up with A, and on the
left-hand side, well, so x.
So that's what we need, we
get whatever when we plug in
x equals 0.
So on this side, we get
1 over 1 plus 0 squared,
so that's just 1.
So the cover up method gives
us that A is equal to 1.
And now we need to
solve for B and C.
And probably the most
straightforward way,
in this case, to
solve for B and C,
is you can always
just multiply through.
And if you multiply
through-- OK.
So we'll multiply through
on the left-hand--
we'll clear denominators,
we'll multiply through
by x times 1 plus x squared.
So on the left we'll get just 1.
On the right-- OK.
So we multiply A over x times
x times 1 plus x squared,
so that gives us A
times 1 plus x squared,
but we know that A
is 1, so this is--
the first term becomes
1 plus x squared,
and the second term we multiply
through by x times 1 plus x
squared, and the 1
plus x squareds cancel,
and we're left with
plus x times B*x plus C.
Now, if you, maybe you
could-- at this point,
there are a number of
different ways to finish.
But one, for example, is
you could see, all right,
if you subtract the 1 plus x
squared over to the other side,
you have minus x
squared, and over here,
you have B x squared plus C*x.
So for those things to be equal,
you need B to be negative 1,
and you need C to be 0.
Right?
So OK.
So good.
So we have B equals
minus 1, C equals 0.
So the partial
fraction decomposition,
then, if we plug this in,
is 1 over x minus x over 1
plus x squared.
So this is the partial
fraction decomposition
of this rational function.
So you apply that partial
fraction decomposition.
What do you do?
All right, So now you carry that
back upstairs to the integral
we were working on.
So our integral
that we started with
is equal to, now-- well, so this
constant is still out in front.
So it's minus 2 arctan
x over x plus-- so
now we've got 2
times-- all right.
So first, this is just
algebra that we've done,
so we can just substitute it in.
So we replace this
1 over x times 1
plus x squared by 1 over x minus
x over 1 plus x squared dx.
OK.
And now using the
properties of integration,
this is a difference of two--
an integral of a difference
is the difference of
the two integrals.
So we just integrate
them separately, right?
So this is equal to-- so OK, the
part out front never changes.
2 arctan x over x,
plus 2 times-- OK.
So you integrate 1 over
x, and that just gives you
ln of absolute value of x.
And OK, so you integrate-- so
the second part is x over 1
plus x squared.
Now, in the worst
case, we would need
to do some more work on this
term and split things up.
And one of them, we might
have to complete the square
or something.
But in this case, it actually
has worked out kind of nicely.
This x over 1 plus x squared
is a simple thing to handle.
That's just ln of
1 plus x squared.
Well, actually, one half
of ln of 1 plus x squared.
So this is minus 1/2
ln of 1 plus x squared.
I could write absolute
value, but 1 plus x squared
is always positive, so it
doesn't matter if I do or not.
And if I wanted, I could
rewrite this a bit.
I could rewrite this
as-- just to finish it,
I could write 2
arctan x over x plus 2
ln absolute value of x minus
ln of 1 plus x squared.
And I was doing
an antiderivative.
So at some point, whenever
I finished the last one,
I should have added a constant.
So this should have
had a plus c here,
and it should have
a plus c there.
Right, good.
So OK, so there's my answer.
And let's just recap quickly
how we arrived at it.
So we started with
this integral.
And we saw, we recognized
it as a good candidate
for integration by parts,
and so we applied integration
by parts, seeing that the arctan
part was the part that really
wanted to be differentiated, and
that the 1 over x squared part,
you know, it could have
been differentiated,
it could've been integrated,
but since the arctan
wanted to be differentiated,
this got integrated.
Good.
So we did integration
by parts, and then we're
left with a rational function
as the piece of the integral we
had left to compute.
So when you have a
rational function,
one method that always
works is that you
can do partial fractions.
Now, in this case, this was a
fairly simple partial fractions
to do.
First of all, the
degree of the numerator
was smaller than the
degree of the denominator,
so we didn't have to
divide by anything,
you know, we didn't have
to do long division.
And the denominator had
a fairly simple form,
so we could just do
the cover up method,
and then multiply through
and be done fairly quickly.
But in any case.
So we did, we applied
partial fractions,
so we got this expression.
So then we carried that
back up to our integral,
and integrated.
OK, so then we had this integral
with the partial fraction
expression in it, and that
was easy to integrate.
So in this case, quite
easy to integrate.
Sometimes it's a little
messier, but we came out
pretty luckily this time.
So OK.
And so there you go.
So that's going to
be our final answer.
Now, this was long
and complicated.
And so sometimes, when you
do a long and complicated
computation, you worry, did
I make any stupid mistakes
along the way?
One way to check, always, when
you've done an antiderivative,
is you could always check,
you could take the derivative
of this expression.
So that'll require you
to use some product
rule and some chain rule.
But, you know,
it's arithmetically
a little difficult, but not
sort of intellectually, right?
You just are applying rules
sort of automatically.
So you can take the
derivative of this expression,
and check to make sure that it
actually agrees with the thing
that we started with.
So good.
I'll end there.